[Música]
Pedro Castillo fue destituido del cargo
de presidente de Perú y está detenido
por las autoridades de ese país por 101
votos El Congreso de Perú aprobó la
moción de censura que puso fin a su
mandato un hecho que tuvo lugar
solamente unas horas después de que el
mismo Castillo anunciara la disolución
del legislativo Tenemos reporte desde la
Ciudad de Lima en unos minutos
ante el pleno del congreso en un acto de
restitución del orden democrático y
constitucional la hasta ahora primera
vicepresidenta de Perú dinavoluarte tomó
posesión del cargo de presidenta en
funciones en reemplazo de Pedro Castillo
se trata de la primera mujer en la
historia en asumir la presidencia de
Perú
y la policía de Alemania frustró un
atentado contra el parlamento de ese
país 25 integrantes de La ultraderecha
alemana fueron arrestados en un
operativo a Escala Nacional según la
fiscalía alemana tenían como objetivo
acabar con el orden Estatal e instalar
un nuevo liderazgo en ese país europeo
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en nuestra
región en América Latina remesón
político en Perú a esta hora el ya
expresidente de ese país Pedro Castillo
se encuentra detenido y bajo custodia
policial así ya lo confirmó la fiscalía
de Perú tras haber anunciado la
disolución del Congreso y la instalación
de un gobierno de emergencia de esta
manera el exmandatario buscaba gobernar
por decreto también convocar a nuevas
elecciones parlamentarias y redactar una
nueva constitución una decisión que fue
mayoritariamente tildada por diferentes
sectores como un golpe de estado en ese
país apenas horas después en una sesión
extraordinaria del Congreso peruano los
parlamentarios votaron por ciento un
votos a favor y seis en contra para
aprobar la moción de censura del
mandatario lo que puso fin a su mandato
como presidente de Perú tan solo 16
meses después de haber asumido el cargo
vamos a ir por supuesto hasta Lima Allí
se encuentra Francisco Zacarías nuestro
corresponsal él se encuentra justamente
en la Plaza Mayor de Lima frente al
palacio de gobierno y nos va a dar más
detalles de esta jornada de este ramesón
político allá en Perú Francisco muy
buenas noches para ustedes allí en la
capital peruana y hablemos de esa
votación en el congreso que puso fin a
este digamos controvertido gobierno de
Pedro Castillo una votación que estaba
prevista para la noche de hoy pero dadas
las acciones de Castillo fue adelantada
por el congreso y ya puso fin a este
gobierno
Santiago Buenas noches una situación de
tensa calma en el Perú los resultados
que se han producido en las últimas
horas Pedro Castillo ha sido declarado
destituido por el parlamento de Perú
quien le declaró la vacancia
presidencial fueron ciento un votos a
favor el presidente del parlamento José
Williams invocando el artículo 113 a la
Constitución peruana adelantó este
proceso precisamente hubo diez
abstenciones y seis legisladores se
opusieron a esto ellos precisamente son
los congresistas integrantes del partido
Perú libre Perú Bicentenario y también
del Bosque el bloque magisterial ellos
son incondicionales a Pedro castillo y
por más que haya seis investigaciones
por presunta corrupción en la fiscalía
peruana ellos se manifiestan que se
trataría de una injusticia y que Pedro
Castillo fue removido injustamente cargo
sin poder este haber hecho el derecho a
la defensa pero Se olvidaron que
previamente Pedro Castillo sin ningún
fundamento cerró el congreso y declaró
el toque de queda por eso la las
instituciones de este país como la
contraloría general de Perú están
abriendo acusaciones contra Pedro
Castillo el ex gobernante se encuentra
en estos momentos en la prefectura de
Lima y el Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres
está cumpliendo las labores de abogado y
de esta forma Francisco se pone punto
final a un capítulo político en Perú y
se abre otro Dina boluarte hasta hoy la
primera viceministra de Perú es ahora la
nueva mandataria de ese país
suramericano y deberá entonces completar
ese mandato que estaba previsto terminar
en julio del 2026 se trata del sexto
mandatario que tiene Perú en un espacio
de cinco años en su toma de juramento
boluarte habló de una tregua política de
la necesidad de crear un gobierno de
unidad nacional al tiempo que indicó
también que combatirá la corrupción con
el apoyo de la fiscalía y de la
contraloría boluarte quien pasa ya a la
historia como la primera mujer en asumir
el cargo de presidenta de Perú deberá
también Buscar la estabilidad política
de ese país Francisco entonces vale
escuchemos la
ha producido un intento de golpe de
estado
una impronta promovida por el señor
Pedro Castillo que no he encontrado eco
en las instituciones de la democracia y
en la calle este congreso de la
República
atendiendo al mandato constitucional ha
tomado una decisión y es mi deber actuar
en consecuencia
asumo el cargo de presidenta
constitucional de la República siendo
consciente de la enorme responsabilidad
que me toca y mi primera invocación como
no podía ser de otra manera es convocar
a la más amplia unidad de todas y todos
los peruanos
[Aplausos]
Dina boluarte la nueva presidenta
interina de Perú Francisco una figura
poco conocida fuera de las fronteras
peruanas de quién se trata quién ASUME
ahora las riendas de este país
Santiago titina boluarte es la primera
mujer en la historia de este país en
ocupar el cargo de presidenta
60 años abogada de profesión viene del
Perú profundo como se dice acá de la
región de Apurímac
un mucha pobreza ella ha sido enfática
al señalar sus orígenes muy Humildes se
ha dicho que tiene el compromiso con el
país con los peruanos con la democracia
y quiere tratar de sacar adelante este
Perú traen el estancamiento económico
tras varios meses de situación política
por motivo de la crisis este país se
encuentra en constantes conflictos Tina
boluarte ha prometido hacer un gobierno
de diálogo y va a depender mucho de los
puentes que ella atienda con el
parlamento sobre todo con los partidos
políticos en especial la derecha porque
el congreso de Perú la le ha suspendido
una investigación que tiene contra ella
por supuesto tráficos de influencias
vamos a ver si en a boluarte logra
consensuar con todas las fuerzas
políticas y realizar un gobierno hasta
el año 2026 vamos a ver si llega hasta
el 2026 Francisco Muchas gracias por
este reporte desde de la Ciudad de Lima
los hechos que han tenido lugar en Perú
Pues por supuesto han tenido eco no
solamente en la región de América Latina
sino también en otros rincones del mundo
y también en los organismos
internacionales el mundo entero sigue
con atención el desarrollo de la
situación política en ese país
suramericano por ejemplo la Organización
de Estados Americanos la oea que
recientemente vale la pena recordar
envió una delegación a Perú para ver de
primera mano cómo estaba la situación
política en Perú ellos felicitaron a
Dina boluarte como nueva presidenta de
ese país de otra parte el presidente
mexicano Andrés Manuel López Obrador
rechazó estos acontecimientos que han
tenido lugar el día de hoy señaló a las
élites económicas y políticas de Perú de
haber provocado la destitución de
Castillo a quien se mostraron dispuestos
a ofrecer asilo en tierras mexicanas
desde Bogotá el gobierno colombiano
también hizo un llamado al diálogo entre
las diferentes facciones políticas de
Perú y también condenó los hechos que
atenten la democracia peruana entre
tanto en Chile lamentaron esta crisis
política pidieron el uso de mecanismos
democráticos para respetar el estado de
derecho en una fecha
y qué futuro Entonces le espera a Pedro
castillo y que futuro también lo espera
entonces a la democracia y a la política
peruana después de la destitución de El
presidente se lo preguntamos a nuestra
invitada Katy segarra ellas politóloga y
nos atiende a esta hora desde la Ciudad
de Lima muy buenas noches señora segarra
Gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
France 24 y la pregunta que se están
haciendo muchos a esta hora que sigue
entonces para Pedro Castillo después de
haber intentado disolver el parlamento
gobernar por decreto convocar a
elecciones parlamentarias y estar ahora
detenido como ya lo confirmó la fiscalía
del país
Qué tal Buenas noches bueno en términos
muy cortos es el fin político de Pedro
Castillo probablemente
sea condenado o entre un juicio en el
cual él tenga no solamente que responder
a la justicia por lo que ha sucedido el
día de hoy que es un intento de gol de
autogolpe sino también por una serie de
investigaciones que ha tenido el ex
presidente peruano en
delitos que se relacionan a la
corrupción de de hecho el presidente
había sido investigado por liderar una
organización criminal Entonces en ese
sentido creo que es el fin de un
político bastante precario que ha sido
Pedro Castillo muy criticado y muy
señalado por diferentes sectores señoras
segarra estos hechos ocurridos en Lima
en Perú el día de hoy pueden poner fin a
esta crisis política que ha vivido el
país en los últimos seis años esta
sucesión de antecedentes de
destituciones De retiros de cambios de
gobierno y de elecciones
lamentablemente no si bien había dicho
que era el fin de Pedro Castillo esto no
significa que sea el fin de la crisis
política de hecho entramos en un
escenario mucho más complicado debido a
que Dina boluarte no tiene el apoyo
parlamentario que sí tenía Pedro
Castillo que de alguna u otra manera
hacía que pudiera sobrevivir en este
caso tenemos a una nueva presidente que
si bien ha pedido el diálogo y el
trabajo en conjunto con el legislativo
creo que va a ser una tarea muy
complicada que lo logre generar en el
sentido de que existe el parlamento por
ejemplo peruano está altamente
fragmentado no solamente no responde a
partidos políticos sino en muchas
ocasiones agendas individuales eso
también se evidencia en el
comportamiento de los congresistas
puesto que las negociaciones No
necesariamente se dan a partir de grupos
legislativos sino a nivel personal
Entonces si bien Dina Volverte Podría
tener o invitar a diversos comentarios y
a sus partidos políticos a
integrarla diversos ministerios dentro
del gabinete esto no le asegura su
permanencia de hecho creo sería muy
importante que los los parlamentarios se
autorregulen y creo que era algo que que
ha faltado muchísimo desde estas crisis
que hemos tenido a partir del 2016
señora justamente le quería preguntar
por el congreso que ha vacado al
presidente un congreso que no goza de
popularidad entre los ciudadanos
peruanos sumamente desprestigiado que
sigue entonces para esta institución
después de los hechos ocurridos hoy de
haber llevado a cabo esta vacancia del
presidente
muchos parlamentarios son considerados
que esto ha sido una victoria bueno ha
sido una victoria de la Democracia no
sin duda alguna pero no es una victoria
de la institución del Congreso es
importante recordar que esta es
es un congreso altamente desconfiado o
altamente impopular por parte de los de
para las y los peruanos en muchas
ocasiones ante esta grave crisis
política la mayoría de ciudadanos según
las encuestas solicitaba que hayan
elecciones presidenciales pero también
parlamentarias ahora sí va a ser Va a
ser importante ver cuál va a ser el
nuevo comportamiento de los legisladores
en el sentido si es que van a estar
continuando teniendo este conflicto
entre con Dina boluarte o van a entrar
en un proceso que que se ha olvidado
parece en la democracia peruana que es
que si bien los poderes se controlan
también pueden cooperar y sería muy
importante que lo hagan
señora Katy segarra en la Ciudad de Lima
Muchas gracias por este análisis para la
audiencia de France 24 Gracias por estar
con nosotros gracias
vamos a cambiar de tema nos vamos ahora
hasta Europa nos vamos a Alemania que
tuvo lugar allí una operación policial a
nivel nacional contra integrantes de
grupos de ultraderecha que planeaban un
ataque terrorista contra el bundestag el
parlamento Alemán en la ciudad de Berlín
hasta el momento este operativo deja 25
detenidos en diferentes estados
federados entre ellos un ex oficial del
ejército alemán quien fue arrestado en
Italia y también un príncipe integrante
de la casa real de Rusia
una gran operación antiterrorista en
Alemania las autoridades federales
detuvieron a 25 hombres sospechosos de
organizar un ataque terrorista contra el
bundestag con el fin de derrocar al
Estado alemán lo sospechosos
pertenecerían al movimiento extrema
derecha rash bulga que niega la
existencia de la República Federal
instaurada luego de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y de la derrota del Tercer Reich
de adolf Hitler en su cuenta de Twitter
el ministro de Justicia marco bushman se
refirió a la operación policial la
democracia ha sido defendida desde esta
mañana está en marcha una gran operación
antiterrorista el fiscal general está
investigando una presunta red terrorista
relacionada con el movimiento ciudadano
del Reich se sospecha que se planeó un
ataque armado contra los órganos
constitucionales
seis de los detenidos se produjeron en
el Estado Sureño de baviera el ministro
del interior bávaro dijo que lo
sospechosos hacen parte de una de las
mayores organizaciones terroristas de
extrema derecha en los últimos años y
detalló los resultados de la operación
hoy se han registrado una gran cantidad
de lugares en baviera total de más de 20
15 presuntos participantes y un total de
seis personas de ese territorio han sido
arrestados como parte de esta operación
nacional y en parte internacional
las redadas contra ultraderechistas se
extendieron a Italia en las céntricas
ciudad de Perú ya la policía italiana
arrestó a un ex oficial del ejército
alemán de 64 años involucrado en el plan
de atacar
la operación en la que participaron más
de 3.000 agentes continúan cuatro
estados alemanes Y recuerda La
desmantelación de recientes planes de la
ultraderecha contra el gobierno alemán
como el intento de secuestro al ministro
de salud
es todo en las noticias buenas noches
[Música]